my name is Deborah muth I am a women's
health nurse practitioner and a doctor
of naturopathic medicine in Wisconsin at
this moment we are funding our business
on our own the business that we're
actually going to pitch for today would
be a marketing business that would allow
the doctors the patients the caregivers
the dispensaries and the cultivators to
all linked up together in a private
setting the risks involved certainly are
that this is a federal crime and I could
go to prison for this and this would be
why my entire family is part of this
right now because we needed to make this
a team a family effort that if we were
getting involved we would all be
involved I'm taking this risk because
it's what our patients need they need
access to safe medications that they can
function on and that are not going to
cause a lot of side effects
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook